I was really
impacted by the murder of Martin Luther
King and I made it a point to get to
know his widow Coretta Scott King
and she was the true queen of America
she's the one
who
really was an amazing Force in the Civil
Rights Movement
she's the one who said to Martin Luther
King we need strategy
we need to be better at strategy and she
says a matter of fact I want you to sit
down
and talk to this guy named byard Rustin
and Martin's like Bayard Rustin
she said yeah he's brilliant
he's black
he happens to be gay
and he happens to be a communist
and and and and Martin said he's gay
like he didn't even hear a communist
he's like Martin's like he's gay he's
like that right right and Coretta Scott
King in 1958 59 said
yeah Martin
he's gay and who do you think we're
fighting for when we fight for civil
rights we're fighting for civil rights
for all people
not just black people and white people
including gay people so I need you to
sit down with him with all your southern
baptist ministers
and Listen to This brilliant man so we
can come up with Strata with strategy
and he said okay Coretta and he did and
he sat down with him and Bayard had just
come back from Paris
and he walked in and he laid it out who
he was
and then he laid out the strategy for
the Montgomery Bus Boycott
and he said this is what we're gonna do
we're gonna stop with the words and the
chanting it's money
we're gonna bankrupt them if they don't
respect us we're gonna knock this in on
the back of the bus the man basically
created ride sharing an Uber before it
was Uber because everybody had to figure
out how to get to point A to point B
without using the bus
and it was that and Coretta said to me
we knew if we could break the South
we could break everything
if we could break Montgomery we could
break the South and we could open up and
get civil rights achieved that was
Coretta Coretta was brilliant the true
Queen
she's the one who made Martin Luther
King's birthday a national holiday
the only American to have his birthday
as a national holiday the only one she's
the one who raised millions of dollars
for the Martin Luther King Center for
non-violent change she's the one who
investigated his true murder and who
actually did it not making a movie about
that and
she's the one who said to me Byron
as black people in this country we had
four major challenges number one end
slavery
nobody's had to deal with that in
America other than us
number two end Jim Crow
and I think Jim Crow
was more damaging than slavery
really yeah because when we were slaves
we were assets
so they protected us right for the most
part when we became free
then we were considered competition and
we became a liability and that's when
the genocide kicked in that's when the
lynchings kicked in
that's when the you know burning us
incarcerating us because you're free and
you're competing with us
I mean what was slavery all about it was
always about money
I brought you here from Africa to make
us rich
not to compete
I brought you here to make us wealthy oh
you're free now now I have to compete
against you let the genocide begin
and that's why you have all the
lynchings and the incarceration and all
the murders because it was always about
money America could never it's
mathematically impossible for America to
become as wealthy as America is without
slave labor and close to 300 years of it
right right we built it together but as
black people we just never got paid
and so then she said
the real reason they killed my Martin
economic inclusion
all right so third one was civil rights
the third one was to achieve civil
rights which is what they did by the
time he was 39 years old and then she
said in the fourth one the fourth one
was economic inclusion and she said
Byron they didn't kill my Martin
over the I have a I have a dream speech
they killed him over the speech he gave
in February of 68 at Stanford University
the other America
and in that speech he said there are two
Americas
one America has access to opportunity
education economic inclusion jobs
the other America doesn't
there are two Americas and two Americas
will not survive
we must achieve one America or America
will fall apart
this is what the great Martin Luther
King Jr taught us well over 50 years ago
and they killed him for four months
later April of 68. he was pushing for
economic inclusion mainly for poor white
Americans
and they were like you're out
[Music]